hi guys it's all red again and today I'm
moving on from the tower to some other
buildings and by the way that skyscraper
has kind of officially been dubbed
coming out our by me right now but that
might of course change when I feel like
now I'm not going to name it that but
for now it's called coming at our but
today I'm actually building three
buildings which in terms of quality oh
pretty consistent if you ask me I kind
of like all three of them equally pretty
cool and the first one is this manner
ish building for which I decided to
basically over use the main street sets
which in hindsight maybe wasn't the
greatest idea because it kind of came
out as once again a theme park ish
building but then again it could be I
don't know a factory or an opposite of
some sort which just wanted to be fancy
in a way so yeah as you can see adding
those very well those signature roofs
that the main street buildings always
have and of course I had some problems
with the corners over there but just
decided to go with that after all but
yeah I do like the general shape and the
look of this building it's just that it
almost feels like it's too fancy to
actually be in a city so maybe it's time
for me to drift away from the idea I'm
just building a city in roller coaster
tycoon 3 and go towards the idea I am
building the ideal city in roller
coaster tycoon 3 though that might also
be dangerous because people would people
could easily say while those buildings
are pretty good but they're not the best
thing that's not an ideal city what are
you doing you know not an ideal city
basically does not exist saying that
you're creating someone something ideal
is always something that yeah it's
something you shouldn't say definitely i
want to be somewhat careful about that
now this point I felt like had a roof
railing and then I felt like no don't
had a roof railing so decided to remove
it but I kept it on the spire just
because fancy spire is fancy so that's
really awesome and at that point I think
that building is pretty much finished
just time for some nice little trees
around it and as always I am kind of
stuck in the pic or where I'm like okay
I want to have a big tree but it doesn't
it shouldn't be too big it shouldn't hit
the buildings it shouldn't be too high
it should be the perfect size it
shouldn't be too small either because
you do want a tree you're not a little
bush something so that's always a bit
hard but decided to go with that and of
course dormers are very important
awnings just because they look fancy so
might as well go for it and then decide
to remove them and replace them with
those because they're even fancier and
of course little path thingies like
those things and planters in terms of
planters and stuff like that also
benches I think this this building came
up pretty nice and at that point I
decided no I'm not going to go with
those bricks I'm just gonna go with the
same floor tile parts and of course add
a little bored around that because I
don't want the new thing is to go
through each other and make the text the
text is glitchy and stuff like that and
of course it's also been spending time
because I don't also i don't i don't
only like spamming flowers i also like
spamming benches because benches are
awesome but anyway it's time to move on
to the next building and this is just
going to be somewhat of an office ish
building one of those office buildings
which are kind of fancy and then my
favorite office buildings because i
don't want my office buildings to just
be well squares cubes basically stuff
like that not the boring old stuff I
want them to at least look fancy you
know how yet sometimes have these
buildings at least over here you have
them where where the where the company
that owns them is basically like okay
when awesome company so you want to work
in an awesome building so that's when
they create buildings like that or at
least get someone to do them but basic
oh wow I just saw over yes I definitely
should have edited that out but whatever
i'm not even going to bother with that
anymore screw it it was just one split
second anyway but anyway yeah i'm
recording with OBS by the way these days
because i used to be recording with
fraps but as you might know for apps
actually records in avi files
uncompressed and they're enormous after
one recording session of what just one
let's play or something like that I
would have 80 gigs of videos that i
would have to render and time ups and
that costs so much space so much more
disk space of course so much time and it
also didn't allow me to do anything
other than that video because as soon as
i recorded one video I wouldn't have any
space left on my laptop so that wouldn't
work out so I'm actually really glad
that I'm recording with OBS right now
because the quality is just a little bit
lower but i think it's it's a it's a
good thing because
but I've now been able to actually bulk
record so this weekend have actually
been recording non-stop pretty much so
that was really awesome but anyway back
to the building as you can see it's kind
of shaping up in a very nice way and I
just felt like adding and blue bored
over there because blue is awesome and I
even got to use my own classical set
which I didn't expect because I don't
really like it as much as I would have
liked to like it that came up weird but
anyway okay I hope you get what I mean
but add that at that point I felt like
hmm I'm just gonna add fancy drawers
underneath it and of course the same old
shy guys windows because why the hell
not because they look great might as
well go for it I might spam the same
window at multiple places but if there's
no window that looks better in a certain
situation well I i guess i can go for it
and of course balconies because
balconies are awesome and let's all
break things and at that point this
building is almost finished because it's
not going to be that complicated oh I
still kind of had to do was add a window
to the war on the back side of that
glass tower but I decided to not even do
it that this episode I don't really
think it matters now at that point I
start building a building which I'm not
even going to finish it and only going
to plan that I'm going to have a little
gallery over there and that's pretty
much it now it's time to move on and add
a building over here I kind of wanted to
create a building that similar to those
two glass buildings that I already have
on the sides there and these are some of
my favorite buildings in the town so I
definitely want it to create something
that would go well with them so there's
quite some experimentation with this one
so I'm sorry if I Bob place things and
then decide to remove them like I'm
doing right now this actually looks
pretty funny didn't even realize that
sometimes time lapsed things are just
better than when they're not time lapsed
and decided to remove that one again
it's just amazing how I only made a 1h
war in this set and then have to deal
with all that placing of hundreds of
walls just to create one buildings and I
decided to just go with her brick
morning just there are simple things I
didn't want to take any risk with this
building simply because I wanted to
create something nice right away and I'm
just going to add a
little little well blue-ish grant glass
tower in front of it and then I felt
like no I need to make it bigger and
then it looks really stupid so I decided
to remove that again and just go with a
small Tower I wish there was actually
like a tower that would be one and a
half squares wide but of course that
with that it's not really possible so i
had to go with this instead but as you
can see at this point the general shape
of the buildings pretty much well
shaping up i guess and that's also well
it's time for me to give tips again
that's also what i usually do and what I
find really works out well is when you
first create a general shape of a
building before you move into the real
details so you can see what it looks
like in its surroundings and then when
you're sure that you want to move on
with it and that you really like the way
it's going to look when it's really
finished with all the details on it then
you decide to add the detail so the way
I did it with this building is just
create the shape first and then put
windows and dormers and all the little
railing things and whatever this stuff
is that I enter to it also these frames
and yeah that basically works out in the
end because I kind of like this building
it's not that complicated it's a pretty
simple building it's honestly its sister
just a cube with a glossy thing in front
but I just like the general idea of
having that so that really worked out in
the end and of course i also like
earning trims everywhere that's
something that I'm really often guilty
of I probably should stop doing for some
buildings because otherwise it's gonna
be everywhere but I don't think I really
care anyway and then I mess with station
gym stormers and that didn't work out in
the end so decided to just describe that
and go with shy guys because they're
awesome and think I'm pretty content
with the colors of this it's kind of as
soon as I did this I i was reminded of
real gun because i have the light bluish
color with the orange brownish color so
that looks pretty funny and i was like
damn it's real going all over again but
it looks good so whatever and then at
that point I'm like why did I remove
those windows I'm not even sure probably
because I didn't want to over use things
but also it looked a bit empty well I
need to give myself
did look a bit empty so it's probably a
good idea to go with those things
instead and of course as always time to
add little things little likes of course
over there and little planters and stuff
like that trees just generally it's
funny when you have a building that's
not as great as we would have liked it
to be I'm just like ma'am I'm just gonna
kind of Sully cover it up with trees
then nobody will be able to see it or at
least kind of drift the attention away
from the ugly parts of the building
towards those little trees next to it so
that's pretty funny and of course it's
time to spare to spam planters on the
side as well did I also put benches over
here I I would be surprised if I didn't
because I I always spam benches
everywhere but it seems like I didn't do
that this time hmm still need to do that
then but anyway thank you so much for
watching this episode and see you on the
next episode in which i'm going to
create one more building and i think
also new skyscrapers so till then